حسنًا، كريستينا يتحدثون عن
التشخيص الخاطئ الذي قد يعني الحصول على
تشخيص خاطئ أو قد يعني المزيد من
التشخيص الضائع مما يعني أنهم
لم يحصلوا على تشخيص على الإطلاق مما
كان يمثل مشكلة حقيقية للمريض،
وما وجدوه كان بعض
الأرقام الكبيرة جدًا  كما ذكرت، أريد التحدث
إلى الناس، تحدثت عن الأشخاص الذين يموتون
سنويًا، كان حوالي 371000 شخص
كل عام، وعن الأشخاص الذين يعانون من
نوع من الإعاقة نتيجة لهؤلاء الأشخاص الذين
غابوا عنهم أو أخطأوا في التشخيص،
424000 شخص هذا ما
أظهرته الدراسة.  أريد أن أوضح أنه
بشكل عام، عند الذهاب إلى المستشفى والذهاب إلى
العيادة، فإن الشخص العادي لديه
فرصة أقل من 1% للإصابة ببعض
المشكلات الخطيرة نتيجة
للتشخيص الخاطئ، ولكن كانت هناك
مناطق معينة كان لديك فيها أكبر المخاوف
مثل السكتة الدماغية  يمكن تفويتها مما
يؤدي إلى نتائج خطيرة،
والالتهاب الرئوي الإنتاني، وتجلط الدم في الوريد مما
قد يؤدي إلى شيء مثل
الانسداد الرئوي على سبيل المثال وسرطان الرئة،
وهذا ما وجدوه كان أكبر
المخاوف بشكل عام مع هذا الآن ما الذي
يحدث بالضبط هنا  لماذا
تحدث هذه التشخيصات الخاطئة؟ هناك عدة
أسباب مختلفة ولكن اسمحوا لي أن أقدم لكم
بعض الأمثلة عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالسكتة الدماغية، فغالبًا ما يعرف الأشخاص ما إذا كنت
تعاني من الضعف، أو إذا كنت تواجه مشكلة في
التحدث بأشياء من هذا القبيل، فهذا
نوع من الإشارة إلى شخص ما.  قد تكون مصابًا
بسكتة دماغية، ولكن ماذا عن
الأعراض الأكثر غموضًا مثل الدوخة والصداع
والتعب التي قد تكون أيضًا
مشكلة لسكتة دماغية أو
إشارة إلى سكتة دماغية أو عندما يتعلق الأمر
بمشاكل في القلب، تعتقد أنه ربما يكون
الألم الكلاسيكي في الجانب الأيسر من الصدر  ولكن
يمكن أن يكون ألمًا أكثر عمومية في الصدر،
وقد يكون نوعًا من الضعف أو
التعب أيضًا، لذا مرة أخرى تكون قادرًا على
الرجوع قليلاً والقول
حسنًا، هذا لا يناسب
النمط الكلاسيكي، هل يمكن أن يكون شيئًا آخر
هذا ما  لقد ركز مؤلفو الدراسة
حقًا على بعض
النصائح وهي أنه يجب أن تكون
واضحًا قدر الإمكان عندما
ترى طبيبك وممرضتك
بشأن ما يحدث وتأكد من
أنك بخير  مؤرخ يمكنه
أيضًا تقديم أدلة يمكن أن تساعد في
زيادة احتمالية حصولك على
التشخيص الصحيح وتأكد أيضًا من طرح هذه
الأسئلة حول ما الذي يمكن أن يسبب
مشكلتي ولكن بعد ذلك أيضًا المتابعة، ما الذي
يمكن أن يجعل الجميع يفكرون
فيه  الاحتمالات الأخرى لما قد
يحدث هناك وإذا كانت هناك
نتائج اختبار متى ستعود نتائج الاختبار هذه يا
كريستينا، فأنت تريد معرفة
ذلك وما هو القرار الذي سيتم
اتخاذه بناءً على نتائج الاختبار هذه لا
يحل هذه الأرقام الضخمة ولكنه
يمكن بالتأكيد أن يحدث فرقًا من حيث
الوصول فعليًا إلى
التشخيص الصحيح أو عدم تفويت التشخيص
في المقام الأول كريستينا